le feu s'est déclaré vers 20h30 hier
soir dans une rue du centre-ville
ravageant cet immeuble mitoyen
ce matin les riverains de cette commune
de 3300 habitants sont sous le choc
je vais jouer à vue du mondial j'ai bien
peur j'ai pas beaucoup dormi et puis bon
ben voilà donc là j'attends sinon j'irai
chez des proches qui appelait les
enfants qui sort en région parisienne en
sortir mais c'est dur le bilan est lourd
un adolescent de 14 ans est décédé
piégés par les flammes au premier étage
trois autres personnes ses parents et un
autre enfant ont été blessés
d'importants moyens ont été mobilisés
sur place qui a fallu qu'on casse à la
masse et le titre forcément un mur en
briques afin de pouvoir faire le
sauvetage de trois personnes à
l'intérieur de cette cour
originaire de la nièvre la famille
sinistrée a d'abord été transporté à
l'hôpital puis recueilli par une élue de
la commune le maire compte désormais sur
la solidarité des habitants et les
parents sont hébergés une de mes
adjointes et là on va se mobiliser parce
qu'ils n'ont plus rien alors trouvé des
habits
voir comment les horlogers pour l'heure
l'origine de l'incendié reste inconnue
certains riverains évoquent une
explosion
la gendarmerie poursuit quant à elle ses
investigations